welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike Hummer we
are here live at the seventh annual
Metro st. Louis class championships with
a guaranteed prize fund of $1500 in
round one my student Justin Zhang rated
900 played Robert lucky rated 1100 now
my student took him bet
Robert lucky in his name lucky you know
decided to eat some lucky strips right
before the game so let's see if the good
luck prevailed for him all right so
Justin has the black pieces here so here
we go all right Robert starts out e4 e5
very good night f3 knight c6 Bishop the
c4 all right
so we've come to a very routine position
and if you've been following my lectures
what move do you think I told him time
and time again you've never played this
move you never play it what move do you
think I'm telling them never to play
Kevin do you have any ideas what move
would I strongly not recommend in this
position well yeah who a queen that
wouldn't be good you know I hate f6 as
we'll see in the next game here but what
do you think Bensimon Knight f6 don't
play Knight f6 because it allows white
to play Knight to g5 and now you're
going to go into the fried liver attack
so I told time and time again I tell my
students if you play it you know you
don't need to begin lessons from me okay
so but he's like he knows better
he's 900 right so he plays it so so
here's the deal if he doesn't win I
don't know if he give me my student
anymore it's like a kid taking a like a
half-court shot in basketball when
there's five minutes the
oh you better make it if you're playing
alright alright so here we go so luckily
Robert does not go in to the fried liver
attack he plays Knight to c3 so it's uh
he's gets rewarded so it brings his
Bishop out here white plays d3 so now
he's going prep to but it's a little
slow little goofy cuz what can white
easily play to protect this F pawn here
Castle yes and and white would love it
if you would go ahead and take this
because then we would take check you
would take and he got rid of blacks to
really active pieces for his rook that
was just back there doing not much all
right
so Justin's a little smarter than that
so he's like I'll Castle too and you
know it looks so fun alright so Bishop
attacks the Queen alright so he just
brings his Bishop back to defend it so
Bishop takes Queen takes Knight d5
attacks the Queen so he's like alright
I'll go back and defend fair enough
alright C 3 d6 Queen to e2 and now he
decides to put his knight back on h6
alright so she's not playing the best
right now but that's ok so white decides
to bring back his knight to e3 so now a
princess Bishop to g4 whenever you play
a chess game and you know you put your
piece where it can get captured always
be expecting it to get captured and
that's exactly what happens in this
position but at least that makes his
knight go to a a better square so Queen
back to its original position he's I
guess he's preparing d4 in this position
here so here's d4 so attacks and now
Bishop to d5 alright so the bishop
Knight and rook are all in the same line
this Knight is in a pin here
so which piece do you think you wouldn't
move in this position right alright I
guess this guy needs a couple more
lessons I guess laughs so in this
position you protect the knight you
don't move it alright so but at least
now he doesn't have to worry about that
pin you know alright he's like alright
yeah yeah so so rookie one protects the
pawn he sees it all right so you tax the
pawn takes takes Queen to d3 so he
brings his knight up the Knights gonna
come in the tax so so things are going
okay for them so rook to e4 Knight
attacks the rook and that rook back so
now black has a tactic here all the
whites pieces are kind of cramped on
this third rank here so what do you
think he does to capitalize on that
efore all right all right just ensues
and now he's got he's got some momentum
here alright so attacks the Queen you
better move it alright so just take it
perfect
alright he's offering the Queen trade
and so instead of really doing anything
about it he just attacks the Queen again
alright let's see how those lucky
stripes are tasting right now for her
adjusted viddy out lucky um all right
everybody see how he just got really
lucky
checkmate alright the Queen you got the
got the the checkmate the queen of the
checkmate all right so all right so my
my student avoided the the fried liver
not not by him by his own but because of
Robert lucky and now he got lucky and
got the checkmate so very good so he's
won an O and he
feeling really good alright so that's
good alright so let's see another game
from a round one in the under 1200 slash
unrated section so here we go
this is from round one Daniel Bart's
1100 playing Nagina in in the under 1200
section so Daniel has white and the
opening kind of starts out pretty
regular you know Rory Lopez instead of
attacking plays Bishop c5
alright c3 trying to get a big center
here
alright pawn takes pawn takes big check
bishop up takes takes gets castle
everybody gets castle alright d5 pawn
attacks the knight Knight up so probably
just wanted to take that but alright
rook to e1 so they take take alright
Bishop attacks the knight doesn't really
have the same sting because there's no
pin going on so you can just move the
knight out all right excellent
alright so now black alright
so whenever you have the opportunity to
play f6 you got to figure out a better
move so so black plays f6 thinking well
it's no big deal here so in this
position just play h6 alright so we're
gonna see how f6 just totally ruins the
position for black here okay
it weakens all your squares and it
allows white to do all kinds of cool
stuff so f6 just horrible okay so they
take it
Queen takes Bishop back now you're
you're attacking that so g6 so notice
that just because you play f6 now your
King side just is not as safe as he as
he was if you would have just played the
move h6 instead of f6 here so h3 Bishop
back
fish up back Queen takes so Queen takes
Knight takes Bishop takes and now now
blacks like I'm the best I am the best
and it's like I got the fork I'm the
best what move should white play to
really put the hurt on on black here all
because blacks got no left pawn and no
hope here any ideas
can you block in you work the e7 us and
this one you would just slam on the
board cuz because there's no defense
there's absolutely no defense it's like
right I got your Brooke and now now
finish black off here Bishop e6 check
yeah excellent you look for checks when
you want to finish somebody now just
find the well there's two checks find
the check that mates work takes 87
checkmate yeah good thing you gotta have
six then huh and yet so f6 always will
crumble your position alright so don't
play f6 here so what I lost my right
yeah yeah you can recover from that
alright so yeah real simple idea and the
best move for black is actually rook
here so after you take and now they take
your rook there you got any ideas here
yeah and you're still just crushing yeah
then your first thing sticks probably
right and just demolish them from there
okay right yeah yeah eventually you're
gonna play rook up but unfortunately
after that they get the check in fish up
up Bishop takes and now you have the
same thing you can just play a rook up
and yeah you're crushing because you're
threatening the the big checkmate again
but you never cease the idea and
unfortunately bad things are happening
so rook check you could just get out of
it but in say he's like Oh our she's
like I don't care I just take you
whatever Bishop takes rook attacks the
bishop the bishop can't go anywhere to
defend c2 because it goes to b3 night
we'll just take it and so now the knight
gets out rook attacks the night so now
they just make a threat greater or equal
you know so okay so Bishop attacks the
night again Knight up gets the King
involved here so they both get the King
up black could consider c5 here instead
he puts the rook knight in the same same
row essentially pinning depending
themself but there's no way that white
can do anything about it so they proceed
so now takes and takes oh so if I was
playing right now and all the rooks just
got traded I would take a deep breath
and I would really start analyzing the
position here I would really see like
what are my goals you know this is this
is like a time where you take a time out
in the game and totally reassess because
this position nothing like this position
has come up in the game so far so this
is when you
we want to assess like your goals if I
was playing black I probably want to get
my king up here that looks pretty good
but maybe I would want them here you
just have to think about it and I'd be
like where do I want my Knight where do
I want my King King in the center is
always good and then when you get up
here then you can decide do I want to go
over every these pawns or go after here
and plus you got to see what White's
idea is so white wants to get his King
to the center so black wants to get his
King to the center but instead he plays
h6 which had nothing to do with anything
if anything it just undefended this pawn
and now his King has to be instead of
his King being able to roam anywhere now
he's got to be a babysitter for that
point not good so they make some moves
so now it's Kings back in the center so
now White's trying to get a passed pawn
created here so let's see if it works so
now so now White's trying to create a
passed pawn what do you think black
should try to do create a passed pawn
yeah and what's the only way to create a
passed pawn in this position for black
a5 yeah the queenside excellent you
definitely want to trade this pawn for
this pawn because by playing b5 now if
you sacrifice your bishop for this pawn
black can always come over and get that
pawn and now he's got an extra guy so
big mistake
sure the traded that was not the correct
way to try to get a passed pawn he's
over here but that's neither here nor
there you see in this position this
would create a passed pawn that move
doesn't act and we want passed pawns and
they're like gold man they could
yes so it's of this bishop better get on
this square right now or else the game's
over or this square alright but he gets
on alright and so now you see what
Nagina just did she just took the pawn
because if Bishop takes the knight this
pawn goes bye-bye and gets a queen so
excellent excellent tactic and that's
pretty much the game I would imagine now
he's like okay I got to get a passed
point here you've ever means given him a
passed pawn or another pest point all
right so does black have anything to
fear if you were playing black what
would you play here all right you lose
the game pick up six yeah you better try
to stop this uh this pawn always one
ways he's grabbing for the Queen yeah we
play King to g7 and then it's Bishop
there whatever and now we're just
and then the gaint game's over right yep
does white have anything to worry about
or just is he going to just come down
and get it what do you think what do you
think yeah that's the only thing you
should be thinking about here
now the moment of truth night to be for
no you can't get in sorry but yeah just
let torment your opponent just a little
bit more yeah you could but but night
before it's a lot funnier like oh so
close any only to touch the night that
gets so excited oh and then then you get
the Queen and then you win alright God
have fun with your opponent alright
there it is alright alright so that was
so much fun it got me inspired I'm gonna
go play a game of chess and go go see
I'm gonna be the house player for round
2 so I'll be back momentarily to show
you my crushing of the guy alright how
do you switch the switch the control up
alright I'm back
I played mister heard alt and I'll put
the hurt on them I had the black pieces
here we go so white starts out efore I
play the Sicilian this guy's rated about
1200
alright so Bishop to c4 tax my off pawn
but I'm not worried about it
so Bishop up D 3 d6 the reason why I
play d6 in this position is because I
want to play my night out but if I play
my night out too soon you can play e5
and that's pretty annoying so we prepare
our moves with d6 Bishop e3 Knight f6 d4
pawn takes Knight takes no reason to
take here we'll get castled now after a
3
could try a complicated line to win this
pawn here with Knight takes Knight takes
and now notice a theme we've seen in a
lot of games these bishops Knights are
all on the same row you can fork them
with the pawn but then you know you know
you could take take but I guess I guess
it would have worked out and it's not
too complicated but I just wanted to
play a play really really safe so I play
Knight to g4 at axis Bishop whenever you
have this kind of dragon formation down
here the last thing you want to ever do
is trade this Bishop because he's
holding everything together without this
Bishop you see out how weak those dark
squares would be and he can try to swoop
in for a checkmate of g7 so I really
like this Bishop here and I really don't
want him to have a dark square bishop so
I attack it
so after takes and takes plays Bishop to
d4 offering the trade of the dark
squared bishop so obviously you know I
don't want to trade here what move can I
make to give me a really big center have
sex yeah f6 f6 in this position f6 is
actually illegal but that's the only
reason why I didn't play it right if it
was legal I probably would have right
but no II five big Center all right and
so now when he plays Bishop back snatch
it off the board giving them these junk
pawns and life is pretty good now I
could give them a check here but does it
do anything not really because this e
pawn is protected by the knight
so just because you see a check doesn't
necessarily mean we want to play it well
notice that this pond is undefended so
we probably want to attack it
is there anybody else of whites that is
undefended this bishop this pawn and g2
so oh so I could play here they actually
did not analyze that in the game if if
we if he plays that he can play a queen
up three or Queen e2 I looked at Queen
to b6 that's what I play Queen B b6
attacking this pawn in this pawn but
there is one way that he can defend both
and as with us Queen okay so so now you
just want to pile on attackers here so
Bishop up to attack the pawn so now he
plays his knight back to defend alright
so I want to remove the defender of the
pawn so the only way he can save this
night is by interference putting his
Bishop on e to here so I'm taking this
cuz now he'll have no opportunity to
castle anymore in the game once he moves
his King so now his King is forever
stuck in the middle of the game in this
middle here so so when a king is stuck
we want to go on the attack here right
so even though these pawns are junk
they're doing a good job of keeping my
pieces you know away from the King so if
I can try to break this up I might be
able to win here so these rooks are are
no good at the moment because they're
not on open files so how can I make my
rooks better how can I try to create an
open file here any ideas so d5 is one
idea and it might actually work just as
well but you see I got my rook on f8
here f5 and f5 is way different than f6
alright so f5 it is
yeah and yeah I don't have to worry
about a LightSquared check or anything
he's got look at all his pieces are on
the back row you think my kings really
worried about them no he's like you know
I can do I could probably play King here
King here and still have the advantage
all right but I won but but I could all
right so now after Knight c3 I
mistakenly don't follow through with my
plan I play here first to attack the
pawn big mistake and now I'm like oh I
got a much better idea so how can I
attack this pawn just one more time
Queen wife isn't that Queen takes the
Queen and Bishop are attacking it who
else can possibly attack yeah just keep
pushing that pawn because we don't want
to we don't want to take here cuz then a
knight would take and it would defend a
lot of those key squares so f4 attack
again replay alright and now Knight
protects so we take the last thing you
finally wants to do was take here but he
does and he put his knight into a pin
right and so what do we want to do to
pin pieces attack them alright so
obviously the Queen and Bishop are
attacking it but he's got two defenders
the king and the Queen we need one more
guy to get in there any ideas so d5 is
an idea but I have a better idea
but d5 probably is pretty good so you
play d5 even B takes takes we'll have
another prone to come up but he might be
able to stop all the shenanigans with c3
maybe but maybe d5 would work
who else could possibly try to get in on
attacking this Knight it's a true move
process and it's not a pawn
how could this work ever attack the
night where would he need to be efore so
get them on f4 and even if he's earring
moves this night somewhere yeah it would
be terrible yeah because we're just
gonna take what check and everything's
gonna be great then we win a queen right
but this is much better how this ends up
so Queen to d1 didn't really do anything
about it so rook takes Queen takes d6
now everybody has a chance to be better
than me cuz I see made in three not made
in two like my opponent he's like whoa
you're so bad why does he made two it's
like yeah well do it I got the victory
okay but but can you guys be better than
me and fine baton to instead of made in
three so what do you think the first
move is yeah of course you want to play
Queen takes a nothing stopping Queen to
e3 so obviously if he goes here I
calculated out this mate I knew it well
actually yeah actually I did I did I did
so everybody see the checkmate in this
position for black Queen e2 excellent
see how that's checkmate because the
bishop stops there so I knew he wasn't
going to go there I so he plays here and
I calculate out made in a main two from
here when it in reality I have made in
one yeah rook F for checkmate instead I
decided to play here and made him with
the bishop I get my bishop and wow he's
the superstar of the game okay
so you know it's all good that was fun
it was very fun let's check out I will
go back with my buddy
Justin all right he's playing a Robert
Beekman all right Robert he he started
playing chess about a year ago or so and
um and you know he finally got some good
result this time so so good for him you
know
it's never too late you know so that's
good all right so let's see what what my
guy does all right Justin ee4 c5 Knight
f3 d6 d4 this is the con variation of
the Sicilian here Knight takes Knight c6
so now Justin's like oh sorry sir sorry
for taking so much of your Center up or
let me retreat here all right so don't
play like that you know just play your
Bishop out you gotta you got to want
that Center okay all right so that's
something I'll talk to him about next
time all right Queen to c7 Bishop to c4
if you were black and somebody played
Bishop to c4 right here would you be
like oh my god you just play Bishop c4
oh that's that's horrible I mean yeah
it's not doing anything it's like biting
at nails man it's like not a very good
place for your Bishop and plus you're
putting them right in the same Lane as
this Queen not a good idea
not good placement all right so Knight
f6 Knight c3 Bishop attacks the knight
think he's gonna do anything about it so
he castles to get out of the pen now if
I was playing black it would be take
this and now he's got double isolated
pawns and an isolated pawn here all
right even though we're you're training
a bishop for a knight they're both were
three and and look I mean these pawns
are major major weaknesses for a white
here all right but but black decides I'm
gonna play Knight to g4 is he really
threatening checkmate
no no because the knight defense h2 but
you throw it out there and maybe white
will make a mistake so if you were
playing white and listening to beginner
breakdown in the last few few times what
do you think White's gonna play here
well what should white play here you
just tell the knight hey get out of my
face here all right just get away right
go away because but by him having this
night out here it is restricting our
night from ever moving and we want to
have all our pieces mobile they say he
plays g3 and yeah it's like it stops the
checkmate that what never was but it's
not the best so after castles now he's
like oh I attacked your queen
did he win when he attacked his queen no
it's just he thought it'd be cool to
attack the coin do you think blacks
gonna see it it's a 50/50 chance all
right he sees it he sees it
all right so Queen back and now Knight
back he's being really slick here
whenever your opponent makes a weak move
like Knight to d2 or something
suspicious like that he's probably got a
little grin on his face it's like you
gotta ask yourself why did he play that
move and it's like oh yeah
he's a kid he's just playing for tricks
okay so does everybody now see why white
played Knight - D - believe it or not
it attacks something so what is now
under attack of blacks the knight yeah
so when you're venture into your
opponent's territory and you're up and
you know you're not protected you got to
watch out that you know pieces are
coming come from all angles to attack
you all right so let's see what happens
here
all right so he plays e5
interesting all right so so now why
should be like great you know I'll take
you you'll take me probably and I'll
take you back and I'm up up up a pawn
that worked out well but he's like no no
he doesn't see that as Nate's under
attack so I'm gonna put a bishop right
where the knight can take it just entice
them even more so let's see let's see
what happens here
so Queen f6 so now after all White's
hard work it all came to fruition he got
what he always wanted this night but
look how it turns out that it's not even
a great move so what move does black
make take a seat what move does black
make - all right he's got he's just
walked in but he knows all the answers
but what is it
d5 excellent so a discovered attack on
the Queen and the bishop but instead he
gets so excited he's like you're the
worst I'll just take it and so he fell
for his very own trick can you believe
it I can all right so pawn takes Queen
takes but he's still alive here you
still got he still got some chances here
so Bishop attacks the Queen Queen moves
rook to e1 protects the bishop I guess
so
now he's like I'm taking this Knight and
I'm taking your double worthless pawn
here so now he gets his pawn rook there
where do you think you would retreat
this bishop - yes
efore right yeah you want your stuff I
mean this guy is a passed pawn this pawn
on c2 I mean I mean he's got some hope
but he's got to be around to have hope
all right but instead he's like oh I'll
have my rook babysit the bishop all
right so now the way that's doing
all right so so Bishop attacks the rook
so so what move do you think Robert just
slammed here yes rook takes me to yeah
who wouldn't want to trade two for one
yeah yeah now we get it yeah two for one
but did he not play it they just go back
and forth no instead he played rook to
d7 so Robert he should have slammed rook
takes Knight but instead plays a rook to
d7 okay so now Bishop the c6 you've got
to be really careful here cuz white just
threatened something that's really big
even though he's losing horribly right
of course but so what move what moves
should black be really afraid of right
now the back row checkmate right so rook
takes b8 so does anybody have any ideas
how to stop it I hope I helped Wilson
comes through because I don't got
nothing what you got all right Burke
takes b1 Burke takes me one now what you
got eight six I'm gonna take your rook
I'm gonna take your book and laugh at
you so hard
anybody got any better ideas than h6 and
rook b8 o rook yeah excellent excellent
just just give me a free Rock at least
didn't get checkmated right yeah all
right what else we got
really rare what you say coming work the
c7 excellent because now I come back and
go check and you're like oh and yeah
everything's great know everything for
black everything's great
alright thank you for nobody suggesting
f6 alright
that made my day at least I taught
somebody something tonight all right
so excellent so so rook to c7 was the
move but if he went with Winston he not
like a little kid I guess and he goes
alright h6 now and that will that'll
stop everything yeah but it lost the
rook and so Bishop takes Bishop back so
now he got he got the your C pawn so so
white here if you count up the material
he's not doing like as bad as you might
think here he's only down a pawn with
two points essentially because the
knight and the rook are worth eight and
he's down upon so he's down two points
so so you just need to get into like one
of those those great positions where you
can't get checked and a fortress like a
four-hour Cobian was talking about okay
getting a fortress and you'll be awesome
but instead you play your F pawn up and
now the checks are just gonna be rolling
in here check check Bishop attacks the
rook now he gets in his check and uh
alright so so so now yeah so now now all
your pieces are just going away really
quick so what's the best check we got
here at somebody besides Wilson here
we're what's a check we just crushed
August so you're attacking the defended
piece let's let's uh so so by playing
Queen e5 you're like yeah a fort you're
working King but guess what the rooks
protected so which
piece of white is not protected here ye
7 e7 but he doesn't see it so don't
worry he's going oh he's going after
this past pawn all right so he wants
everything all right so first he starts
with the pond all right so so rook here
Jackie right Queen to a6 check
bye-bye rook check again yeah
bye-bye Bishop and now how do we say
bye-bye to the night the Queen a5 check
anything works Queen a5 Queen up to
whatever you'll want even Queen to d7
Wow any way to take it now let's try to
find the checkmate that Robert couldn't
couldn't all right so this King this is
the fortress he was imagining that
guests get rid of all my pieces and now
I'm in a fortress here all right but no
matter what Black has checkmate into
here can we find it now if you don't
have it don't say if it doesn't result
in checkmate it - all right here's the
moment of truth wins then which one
neither neither alright remember
remember white is going to take this
pawn ok and then he's gonna have King 2h
forward - flee - so you have to go to a
square that attacks h4 here all right
Wilson knows so Queen - e1
Queen to e1 and now he's in zog's Wang
where as he likes to say Zags Wang
alright so after takes where it looks
like checkmate them me got no place to
go yep there's a lot of different
checkmates here and can even play Queen
to d5 at least that's what the computer
told me and then after it takes now
maybe the computer didn't tell me that
obviously yeah yeah cuz takes and you
get to h1 and checkmate you got all the
mates Queen eh eh I guess there's like
any move mate that's a good position to
have okay alright thank you all for
coming to a beginner breakdown live at
the Metroplex Championships all right